the revolution will not  be circumcised  thank you please next up can we have  sarah and sarah  didn't know you're gonna be here  what's up yeah i'm sarah  i'm going to speak some words these  words aren't mine  they're written by fez fizz my  granddad's favorite poet  so yeah  i want to dedicate this to a new friend  speak for your two lips  are free speak  for your tongue is still your own  this straight body still is yours speak  your life is still your own  see how in the blacksmith's forge flames  leap high and steel glows red  padlocks open and wide their jaws every  chains embrace  outspread time enough is this brief hour  until body and tongue lie dead  speak for truth is living yet  speak whatever must be said  you